Abbey is in Ohio Abbey welcome to the
Dave Ramsey show thank you so much for
taking my call it's an honor to speak
with you you too what's up well I am in
a very unique position I am going to be
turning 40 this year and I lost my
husband in an accident about a year ago
so this year has been a little
challenging but I do have thank you but
I do have some positives but Mike my
question for you today is and I've had
many fun things I put fun in quotes they
have to deal with this last year but I'm
to a point where I do not have any debt
and I have college paid for for my
children I have two little one and I
have a very I'm very blessed with I have
a great job and the pediatrician so I'm
in a very good position and I kind of
was always the fergal person of the
relationship before he passed away but
my question for you is as I'm trying to
plan for retirement and I'm in the
process of converting a traditional IRA
to a Roth which will be happening over
the course the next few years I maxed
out my retirement at work and they
recently added a Roth 401 K which to
contribute to so I'm not I'm just
curious they only match 3% and so and
I'm a high earner obviously so I was
curious do I contribute obviously there
to match the 401 K and then do I put
money towards the Roth 401 K or do I do
the 403 B I'm not exactly sure which
direction to go I would do the Roth 401
K between those two choosing between
those two okay
the rule of thumb is match it's kind of
rock-paper-scissors match beats Roth
beech traditional mm-hmm so you're
pecking order you take all the match and
in your case your match happens to be in
a Roth 401 K and then you would take
that Roth 401 K and max it what is your
income this year I'll probably do I
hustle hard so it's probably going to be
about 250 good for you okay you also can
you cannot qualify through the front
door on a Roth IRA but you can do what's
called a back
door roth yeah that's that's what I'm
planning to do that's what I've actually
started the process of but because it's
a can they say don't touch it for three
years as we're converting the amount
over that you have currently and so I'm
leaving that be and what I plan to do
yeah whatever the total fifteen percent
of my contribution towards retirement
would be at this point I'm just going to
open a brokerage account and put some
money in mutual funds of what the
difference would be between what I'm
contributing at work and what I would be
contributing on top of whatever the
fifteen percent total would be so I'm
not sure if there's fifteen percent with
just the 401k but you can all live it
also do another six thousand dollars in
addition to your 401k with with a
backdoor Roth and if you've got some
existing funds that you're converting to
Roth you could use the taxes that that
creates towards your fifteen percent
because it's effectively an investment
it's effectively investing and then
beyond that I want you to get on the
house and get it paid off you have your
emergency fund free accept my house
right I'll ever know everything's paid
off I was there life insurance or you
just had it all together no no I had
life insurance before my husband passed
I had a pretty good emergency fund that
I was willing or was about ready to put
all of that towards the last of my
student loan debt but I had for medical
school and then he passed so I'm glad I
didn't do it because I cash flowed some
expenses that he entered the marriage
with that I assumed obviously no there
was no I had a life insurance I'd that L
is a separate but yeah I I just want to
tell you I was you have been a godsend
I've listened to you so much in the last
year and I tell every medical student
and resident and high school student and
college student that rotates with me
that they have got to listen to you to
protect some from bad decisions like
taking out tons of student loans because
it's just a racket and although I'm so
grateful for all of your advice well
thank you I'm sorry you've had the year
you've had but I'm glad that I'm glad we
were able to help you in any time you
need help you just give me a yell back